so like what made you want to move to
japan in the first place well
was it your love for anime or games or
music
well as i've mentioned before um the
only reason that i'm here with you guys
right now is because i actually live in
the underworld
right right the other side the other
side of
i'm
yeah it's okay i live on i live on the
flip side basically i live on the flip
side
so basically the main reason that i
wanted to be in this general area i
guess was just because
um i love japanese music and i have
a bunch of i guess nakama i suppose um
that i want to be close to
right um yeah yeah yeah
and and hang out with and make music
together um
and just just do fun stuff and i
couldn't i couldn't do that where i was
before
right um and now that i'm able to
everything is so much better and i
instantly feel so much better about
existence and it's great
um and i hope that i can continue
chasing my dreams here
um because when i first arrived uh it's
like
everything uh that could go wrong went
wrong
and i was in a terrible place when i
first came did you get like the culture
shock of moving here and everything like
that
yeah definitely and not knowing not
knowing any japanese at all
um etc and having to figure out
everything
on my own having no no no souls no money
nothing you didn't have any friends here
or anything either um i did from the
internet uh but i was not
in i was not located in a place where i
could hang out with them
i guess okay uh so yeah it was just not
great
we had a hard enough time moving here
when we one know each other and to have
an agency helping us so i can't imagine
how it was for you
yeah it was something else but you know
every i look at it this way
every single day i get a little bit
closer to being at the exact place that
i want to be
that i thought of like three years ago
when i set out to do all this
that's progress right yeah yeah
absolutely
yeah because nothing sucks more than you
know working towards something and then
three years passes and you're like oh
i'm still here yeah yeah yeah i mean
like i've heard your japanese
in your streams yeah and it's like it's
definitely
fine like like you you definitely sound
like you know well no i mean
it's definitely super clear no it's okay
i'm not saying you're like you know like
super fluent or anything
like it is definitely more than
sufficient enough to like get by here
right
yeah to get by right now
yeah well thank you that feels good to
know you don't suck like a scallion yeah
as as you said earlier you're japanese
good kali thank you just really really
despite my really really uh like
like i really really can't say things in
a way that is natural i feel that that
like adds like a completely like
different type of charm to it though
well that's what keys and kiara were
saying when i was saying things
strangely when we did our collab as they
were laughing so much and i said
i'm saying things weird and they said no
it's cute like it's funny and i'm like
really you don't think it sounds like
like [ __ ] up and like it makes you
like like me less they're like no
no there's like it's like it's like a
weird innocence to it yeah i think
everyone likes like the other accent
yeah where they struggle it's really
endearing because yeah
they're trying so hard it's like you
know witnessing like a japanese person
and trying to speak to you in english
but
like you hear it and it's clearly broken
but there's like a weird chant all right
because he's like
we have an entire [ __ ] genre of clips
where it's just youtube was trying to
say it's trying to speak english yeah
right
that's true like those usually do like
the best because it's just so endearing
that
you you look at and you're like oh man
they're trying so hard it's so [ __ ]
cute yeah
when that dog said i love you i felt
that yes
i mean right yeah like yeah like that
the whole reason why like you know
coroner's
english only streams do so [ __ ] well
is because it's literally that for like
two hours yeah right it's just clips
galore right so i i think like in
you know in the opposite way like i
think you're able to achieve that as
well when you speak japanese like i'm
sure japanese people are like
oh man like she's clearly trying yeah
like the fact that it's not
exactly perfect is like what makes it
endearing right
yeah that's a good point actually yeah
now that you see because i certainly
don't get that when i speak japanese
right oh yeah
they're like oh man he's trying his best
it's more like holy [ __ ]
why exactly right yeah okay do you do
when you're in japan do people assume
you're japanese or no
it's weird that looks japanese what the
[ __ ] that looks
like
it's really weird right because like
whenever i'm walking with like say aki
uh she's usually the one that gets
approached in japanese
yeah because she looks more asian than i
do and then when
the opposite effect happens where she
can't speak a word of japanese and yet
i can is where like the whole like
what happens right i remember like when
i used to intern at like a
a tech agency here like during uni right
i used to be the guy who had to like
invite uh guests in for like during
business meetings for that company
so i was the one on the phone organizing
like the time and days and you know
being like okay i'll come down and you
know get you from the bottom floor so
you know bring you into the office yeah
and every time i did that
they i'm sure they were expecting you
know a super japanese dude to come down
from the elevator
but the moment they at the elevator
opens and they just see this white dude
come out
they're like you're the guy we just
talked on the phone right and i'm like
yeah
and they're like okay ah this is weird
it happened every [ __ ] time yeah like
yeah i never get used to it
especially oh dude every time someone at
the [ __ ] corn mini me
oh geez do you get any hong kong a lot
all the time but what's interesting
about that is that when they say it to
you that's how you know it's not josie
yeah yeah
you know that's how you're really
hungover
is on the podcast i don't think so
nihongo jozu just means you're very good
at japanese
yeah right basically which is basically
like what they say to every foreigner
who attempts to speak japanese yeah
like if you're actually fluent in
japanese they won't go nihongo josie
yeah right
yeah yeah exactly like it's only when
it's like you know your japanese is like
broken when you get the nihongo yeah no
it's not
it just feels like condescending yeah
exactly like oh nihongo jozu
yeah i think you get it every time yeah
it's like all i said was arigato i'm not
[ __ ]
joking about it yeah can say it shows it
from saying
that yeah yep just the one word and
they're like
that's like that's like if a japanese
person came up to me and said thank you
you don't go oh eggo josue
ordering in japanese at a restaurant and
then like as you're talking in japanese
like to them they'll be like oh here's
the english menu and i'm like
but i was just i was just talking in
your life and then you keep talking to
them in japanese and they keep talking
to you in english
yeah yeah exactly but the way that i try
to think about it somebody said it
really well before to me when i was kind
of like i wish that they would stop
um what someone said to me was well it's
not it's not about you it's about them
you know it's they want to be polite
i guess and it's just their sense of
like you know like very kind
being kind and polite to you right it's
more about about them and not about you
so try and think of it that way kind of
thing but i'll just complain about
everything so
far operation i'd be like bloody oh that
took a [ __ ] long time didn't it jesus
christ you know what the worst
i'm sorry the worst though then like at
nihongo jozu is like when
i get this all the [ __ ] time because
like they always ask
you oh right and you speak japanese
right
and of course i say like yeah yeah and
they're like oh okay
ingredients
never gonna matter